if a wrestler wins in the ring could
your draftking say you made money
not cha-ching
the WWE is reportedly and talks to
legalize betting on high profile matches
as if any of them could be high profile
now that I'm wrestling for the NWA
instead
you think the NWA stands for National
wrestling Alliance but really it stands
for no women allowed
sources say the WWE would work with an
accounting firm to keep the scripted
matches secret so leaks of the winner
wouldn't happened and betting would be
fair
we reached out for the mafia for a
comment but a spokesman says they don't
exist
to make leaks less likely sources say
even the wrestlers wouldn't know what
was going who was going to win until
right before the match
to make the leaks even less likely they
will make sure not to store the secret
winners names in Wuhan
[Music]
which wouldn't really work for me at the
NWA because all I do is win foreign
I mean literally I've defeated more men
than divorce
wait I even got defeated but anyway
some experts say this could lead to
legalized betting on other scripted
things like character deaths and TV
series or in other words the kind of TV
that chicks watch
you know like Jesse Waters
why do we hate it
Lee you're a big wrestling fan right do
you think betting on
what affectionately is simulated combat
with a predetermined
finish I guess if you want to be about
it uh do you think that's a good idea no
it's a terrible idea you should not be
betting on a rigged sports event now
people say well I should be able to you
know Kennedy has a a well uh
well-regarded libertarian streak you
know the the freedom of making that
decision to part with your hard-earned
money the idea of putting it on a rigged
sporting event is something that I
believe is just throwing your money down
the the tubes
unless of course you get the leak right
Kennedy that's what they're
thank you but
if they get a 20-minute heads up that
they're going to win a match they're
going to be texting their friends and
their family members who will be texting
cousin out of here probably picking up
the phone and calling cousin that
because they don't have a cell phone
right who will be placing bets on the
match and winning so yes there are
enough people who know about the outcome
that it is not going to work in
everyone's favor but it certainly will
work in their favor if people are dumb
enough to bet on fake wrestling then
they should absolutely have that
opportunity it's like it's like
Financial Darwinism
could we not use the f word okay
the media is fake wrestling simulated
combat okay we just can we just say that
it's as fake as Meg Ryan's orgasm When
Harry Met Sally
that was fake
well damn Dagan well I'm just I'm
getting out of the line of fire okay I
I'm afraid let me ask you this because I
don't want you to hit me in the nose no
um if okay Kennedy's one of the biggest
supporters of wrestlers there are I
don't know how many wrestlers she's
brought on the show but literally
everyone's gone through wait I'm not
trying to say everyone's gone through
Kennedy's show first before they've gone
anywhere else so I mean she's helped a
lot there's been a list a long list of
guys that she supported so she's she's
not dissing she's just keeping it real
um so real
my mama
my gambling over here am I wrestling
over here you keep them separated
scratch tickets and wrestling so I don't
know I I don't see how it would make any
sense betting on matches and it's
organized
athleticism that's how I would describe
it thank you
I and I'm having
and I'm having a hard time keeping these
alligators down all right whoa foreign
do you bet on anything
I bet every single day we all do
that's what life is right like you make
decisions and you're like this will be
the one that'll be good for me and
sometimes you lose
I like I take Market risk every time I
open my mouth right like I like I say
this okay I'm gonna say this thing this
will be a fine thing to say sometimes it
wasn't right you know it's risky every
day so but with money no I don't bet
just with you know with my life every
day when I wake up
that's kind of the same thing yeah I
guess you six on one hand half a dozen
on the other look I you know what I used
to when you're with your buddies and you
just make it a friendly you know keep it
under like two bucks or something I
wouldn't I wouldn't bet the farm on uh
whether someone's gonna win a wrestling
match or not but I also wouldn't do it
with football NBA or anything like that
or like keeping money in your pocket you
know that would be my advice you know
and uh speaking of that I want to bet
actually I can got to bet with you I got
a new action figure coming out the
All-American Tyra Smash and I bet we can
break the record that we did last time
with major podsmerch.com so there bet on
that but up next
foreign
up next a pleasant Little tune Gone Too
Soon
if you'll be in the New York area and
would like free tickets to see Gutfeld
go to foxnews.com Gutfeld and click on
the link to join our studio audience hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else